nicki minaj turn turn up the whop turn
down the hey maybe we should question
authority turn up the dr fouchy sexiest
man in the world turn down the hey you
know what maybe it's not my role as a
comedian to force you to get vaccinated
this is this is where we are we used to
think that social media uh actually
allowed us to to bypass gatekeepers and
now they have become the most powerful
gatekeepers who have ever existed
because they're worried about losing the
stranglehold information you're about to
say something before well it's just that
you have 74 ish of the black community
that's not vaccinated which means that
they have questions right you have all
these supposedly left-wing talk show
hosts that have spent the last two years
saying that they're completely for the
black people but the second that they
have an opinion or even a question that
goes against what their narrative might
be all of a sudden everybody turns on
them right and that's what i just find
to be disgraceful and with colbert it's
like do you think what nicki minaj
asking a question is somehow more
egregious than i don't know a dancing
cartoon needles